not my job to answer your questions I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV is
the only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
that on TV on radio
and on your smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on peor on sense that he's
one of the most incisive and to many
incend commentators in US politics and
as of this week extraordinarily he's the
chart topping rap Mega star yes really
brace yourself Ben chapiro is back and
he's very
[Music]
unsensed live from the news building in
London this is Pierce Morgan uncensored
good evening from lond welcome to Piers
Morgan on sensor Ben Shapiro is one of
the most talked about political pundits
on the planet when he sounds off people
listen and as of this week they've been
listening to him rapping Yes you heard
that correctly the man who once
infamously said fact rap isn't music and
if you think it is your stupid sparking
International outrage currently has this
is true the number one HP pop single in
the United States we'll find out why and
frankly how a little later when he's not
dropping the rap beats Ben Shapiro's day
job is dropping hard truths at least
that's how he sees it he's incisive and
as I say to some incur takes on Politics
on Trump on liberal insanity and of
course on the Israel Hamas war of
putting front and center of the debates
we're all having so tonight I'm going to
have a few debates myself with Ben
Shapiro and then we host of the Ben
Shapiro show an editor of emeritus of
the daily wire joins me now Ben well
first of all I don't know quite how to
say this with a straight face but
congratulations on being the number one
rap hipop star in the
world so first of all you shouldn't say
that with the straight phase because
it's legitimately the funniest thing
maybe in the history of mankind it's
ridiculous and silly and hilarious and
yes we're very much for it so yo yo yo
from Dr Dr to you well we're gonna we're
gonna come back to your hip-hop career a
little later but let's just uh focus on
where we left off last time I
interviewed you four days after the
appalling Terror attacks of October the
7th when emotions were very raw uh and I
asked you directly then uh about what
you felt would be a proportionate
response by Israel to what Hamas did on
that terrible day and this is what you
said frankly I don't believe in
proportionate response to terrorism I
believe that the way that you stop
terrorism is with wildly
disproportionate response that doesn't
mean in terms of targeting civilians
means in terms of killing as many
terrorists as humanly possible so my
question is today what is the going rate
today for human lives I mean 2014 was a
great year for Ben Shapiro 88 Israelis
were died and there was
2329 Palestinians killed on the other
side that is one Israeli for 27 uh
Palestinian that is a very good exchange
rate what I'm saying is what is the
exchange rate for today so you guys will
be happy so that was bassam's response
to you saying
effectively when you deal with terrorism
there should be no sense of proportion
um first of all your response to what he
said
that listen bosam is a very smart guy
and I don't think that sarcasm or bad
analogies or moral equivalent are really
substitutes for realism or moral clarity
about situations like fighting terrorism
no one wants civilians to die except for
Hamas Hamas actually does want civilians
to die but nobody rejoices when civilian
side no one is looking for an exchange
rate of death for death the point that I
was making is that when you are talking
about for example legal proportionality
in terms of just War what you're talking
is about proportionality to achieve your
target there is no actual math that goes
into a war where you say if a certain
number of people die on this side versus
a certain number of people die on that
side therefore the war is unjust that's
not exactly how War Works war is geared
toward achieving a certain goal
achieving that goal if it is a moral
goal is moral and then the question is
what is the minimum amount of force that
you need to use in order to achieve that
goal that's what we were talking about
when we talk about proportionality when
you're fighting a war like Israel is
currently fighting in the Gaza Strip in
which Hamas has embedded itself in
virtually every area of life in civilian
neighborhoods in schools in hospitals in
in SE beneath cemeteries when when you
see Hamas do this sort of stuff the
question is what level of force must
Israel use in order to extrap that
terrorist presence and that terrorist
threat and frankly Israel would love to
do that with the minimum of both
Palestinian death and Israeli death
considering that more than Israeli
soldiers have been killed in the Gaza
Strip I mean I'm I'm one degree removed
from three of the soldiers whove been
killed in the Gaza Strip that for Israel
that's that's a heavy burden beyond that
Israel has no interest in Mass killing
of Palestinians they were perfectly
happy to leave the Gaza Strip completely
alone despite heavy rocket fire for
fullon 20 years from 2005 all the way up
till 2023 it's 18 years and Israel did
not participate in for example the kind
of action that you are seeing which is a
direct result of October 7th the goal
for Israel is to extrap Hamas all of
this could be over literally tomorrow
and and by the way every day since
October 7th if the leaders of Hamas
walked out held their hands up took
deportation not we're not even talking
about an Israeli jail there's probably a
deal deal on the table right now for
Hamas leaders to actually be sent just
to some third party country if they were
to surrender the hostages surrender
power and leave this war would be over
like immediately okay well let me tell
will not do that they've been firing
Rockets into Tel Aviv literally this
week right let me take you up on that CU
I don't think it would end that way
because I think the trouble with what's
been going on since we last spoke in
terms of proportion is I saw a BBC
report yesterday uh that the UN were
reporting that 19,000 children in Gaza
have now been orphaned another 10,000
children are reported by the Hamas run
uh Palestinian health authority have
been killed 50 to 60% of gazan buildings
have been severely damaged or completely
destroyed and I don't see any any
nearness to the end of this because by
Israel's own numbers they only killed if
you believe their numbers and I'm not
quite sure how they know this under
10,000 Hamas terrorists that means that
you know two-thirds of the Hamas
terrorists are still to be taken out so
this could go on for many months maybe a
year and those numbers of civilians
being killed will exponentially rise and
the devastation in Gaza will reach a
point where there is no real Gaza left
and I don't understand here Ben what the
end game is for Israel I'm not even sure
they've worked it out themselves other
than to just obliterate everything in
what many see as an overreaction to what
happened by a superpower that hasn't
thought through the consequences of
taking out the whole of
Gaza it's certainly hard to deem an
overreaction to the murder of 1200 of
your citizens and more than a 100
hostages still being kept by a terror
group in destroying buildings for
example right now what Israel is
attempting to do and what the long-term
plan is going to be and I said this in
the inter interview as you recall days
after October 7th is that there would in
fact be a long-term military occupation
of Gaza the question is going to be when
Israel shifts its strategy from a high
intensity campaign to a lower intensity
occupation which is predictably going to
be the result of all of this because
again the governing power in Gaza is
still Hamas when Hamas is no longer the
governing power the question is going to
be what replaces it unfortunately
there's been no power other than Israel
that has been willing to actually take
up that question simply because the
Palestinian Authority is incapable of
even running the West Bank palesi
Authority is deeply unpopular even in
the West Bank the Palestinian Authority
is itself r with corruption and Jew
hatred there's literally law on the
books in the Palestinian Authority pay
for slay that actually pays people for
the killing of Jews so that is not a
power that can be in charge of the Gaza
Strip that will leave Israel with any
sort of sense of security the UAE has no
interest in running the Gaza Strip Egypt
has no interest in running the Gaza
Strip Jordan has no interest in running
the Gaza Strip Saudi has no interest in
running the Gaza Strip the United States
obviously has no interest in running the
Gaza Strip so the question becomes who
runs the Gaza Strip and if you are
Israel that question is not a question
for distant day that is a question for
every day and right now the military is
effectively in control of the Gaza Strip
and that is likely to remain until there
is some form of regime in the Gaza Strip
that can be put in place that will end
with the extrap of terrorism that cannot
involve the unrwa which is a terror
Haven that cannot involve the UN because
the un unfortunately has been cover for
Hamas for literally 20 years and so the
question here is a tough one and it's
not an answerable one in kind of right
now and that's sort of the problem just
because there's is no good answer to the
question doesn't mean that the question
isn't urgent or that there is an
alternative option available to what
Israel is doing what what I've been
missing in all this is what exactly is
the alternative option that has been
presented by anyone other than Israel
continuing on its quest to extrap Hamas
so long as Hamas is holding its citizens
firing Rockets into the center of Israel
and threatening Israeli life okay my
response to that would be that I think
it's morally incumbent on Israel who
I've already said many times and believe
to this day have not just a moral uh
right to defend themselves but a duty to
their citizens to do so so let's just
park that to one side my position on
that has not changed it's just how
they've gone about it and you know only
yesterday we saw Israel forces dressing
up um both as you know in in Hamas style
cloth and Palestinian cloth to go into a
hospital on the West Bank and take out
three Hamas terrorists um and there were
many people uh you know impartial
observers you say that what they did
there contravenes international law that
there effectively committing war crimes
uh because it's a violation of
international law to feain protected spe
uh status in this case by dressing up as
a doctor or patient in order to invite
the confidence of the adversary and then
proceed to kill or injure them and it's
also against international law for
combatants who've been incapacitated by
wounds or sickness and are protected
from Attack as persons order combat so
if they're paralyzed or incapacitated an
attack on that individual is prohibited
by international law so I look at that
it seems to be a a primery case of
Israel breaking the law uh do you defend
that yes I defend that because if Hamas
or in this case Islamic Jihad is using a
hospital as a terror base which theyve
historically done then the violation of
international law is on them I mean by
all international law using a hospital
as a terror base which we have seen in
the Gaza Strip we're currently seeing in
the West Bank as well that's the war
crime I always find it very bizarre that
international law is invoked when it
comes to a response to a war crime but
not to the original War crime if you use
a hospital as a terror base then the
hospital is no longer only a hospital it
also becomes a site from which terror is
emanating and so when Israel engages in
a targeted military operation by the way
not killing any civilians in this
particular operation killing people who
are clearly terrorists that is the war
crime as opposed to terrorists using the
hospital as an organizing base that
seems to me peculiar well it is by the
letter of the law of international law
yeah it is what they was a war crime you
you can't dress up effectively as uh
doctors and patients uh and take out
people who are being treated which is
what appears to have
happened well it's unclear whether
they're being treated or whether they're
simply using the hospital as cover
that's Israel's contention anyway the
look I I think that the problem is when
you talk about this you talk with great
uh Clarity and you have a certainty
about how you think this all plays out I
think what you may underestimate and
correct me if you disagree with this but
I don't understand how the kind of
Devastation we're seeing now in Gaza the
kind of huge death toll on children and
women in particular who have nothing to
do with this obviously how that is going
to not just lead to a whole new
radicalization of Palestinians that will
replace Hamas so yeah Hamas May well get
permanently dismantled uh they're
clearly being killed in large numbers
and clearly the underground tunnel
operation are being dismantled and and
netan has made it clear he'll keep going
until the end so assume that Hamas are
removed effectively um why do you think
Ben that doing this in the way that
Israel is doing it is not just going to
lead to a whole new breeding ground of
radicalized Palestinians who've lost
family members kids wives and so on and
who will want to exact Revenge how does
it make Israel
safer it makes is Israel safer by not
allowing the governing party in that
region to actually be fting the violence
providing Weaponry providing education
to small children that reinforces all of
the Jew hatred and anti-Semitism that
has been reinforced in these areas
that's sort of like asking in the
aftermath of World War II there have
been so much unbelievable Devastation in
Germany in Italy throughout Continental
Europe how is it the Western Powers
could expect that there wouldn't be an
entire generation of people who would
rise up in Revenge for all of that and
the answer is that a rebuilding process
is going to have to take place this is
currently why from my understanding
Israel is negotiating with the United
States trying to bring in the UAE trying
to bring Saudi Arabia to essentially put
in place some sort of Marshal plan for
the rebuilding of the Gaza Strip that's
going to take outside money that's going
to take a long-term effort this is not
something that can happen overnight I
think one of the big problems in foreign
policy is very often that people are
looking for the immediate solution at
the expense of the realistic solution
and the realistic solution in an area of
the world where conflicts go thousands
of years deep is not something that's
going to happen next week is going to
have to actually require heavy
rebuilding heavy monetary investment but
monetary investment not via groups that
are linked to Terror and sponsor Terror
and fent Terror but linked to groups
that actually are going to promote
quiessence that are actually going to
promote moderation that are actually
going to promote a future in this region
of the world where both parties can
coexist when I interviewed you I later
interviewed Andrew Tate several weeks
later in Romania and he said
this so Ben is a warmonger Ben has been
wrong on basically every single issue
you can name he was with you with the
vaccine and and every other War Ben is
always calling for other people's young
men to go and die in some War he seems
to love it I don't know if he has short
man syndrome but he's always behind his
desk calling about how important it is
that big strong men like me go and
die I mean apart from the pur name
calling and stuff his point there that
you're a warmonger your
response I mean if the question is
whether Israel has a right to defend
itself the answer is of course and if
the idea is that somehow I'm asking
Israeli soldiers to die Israel is quite
unified in its goals so I'm not sure
exactly who he's talking about the sort
of chickenhawk argument simply would not
even apply under these circumstances as
far as War I think that every single
conflict the United States should get in
I'm an American citizen I'm an American
every conflict the United States gets in
ought to be we ought to be asking what
is the actual American goal what is the
actual American interest which is for
one reason why I didn't support the war
in Libya during the Obama Administration
it's why I was very skeptical of
American interventionism whether covert
or over during the Arab Spring I thought
that was going to end quite poorly so
you know again I think that that's in
accurate but it's Andrew Tade so I'm not
supremely surprised by that I'm not sure
you know exactly what his level of
knowledge is on on foreign policy issues
other than sort of the bragado doio and
his thing that he's a big guy tough guy
and you've got small man
syndrome uh I'm not sure what to make of
that I mean I I guess that you know if
if your version of manhood is walking
around shirtless smoking cigars in
Romania uh then I guess you can you can
have that that's okay I mean sure my
version of masculinity is a little bit
different it's you know being married
with four children and raising a family
in a solid Community but I guess te his
own do you think Andrew Tate is a good
influence on young men in particular
around the world seems to have a very
big one is it a good
one uh I think that Andrew Tate says as
I've said on your show before I think
that he his diagnosis of some problems
is correct uh I think that his his
actual prognosis uh and recommendations
for solving those problems is is more
frequently than not deeply incorrect you
tweeted something uh yesterday I think
which got a lot of attention online let
really quickly quickly uh ask you about
this um involves a woman called Rachel
Cory uh so I'm sorry it was it was
posted yesterday uh it was you
originally tweeted it in 2011 and you
said I would love to write a book called
great idiots of History Rachel Cory
would make the list and it got retweeted
yesterday and started fizzing around the
internet when you look back at that
tweet do you have any regrets about the
way you phrase
that not particularly I mean I think
that Rachel Corey her death was tragic
but that doesn't mean that she wasn't
engaged in deep foolishness that that
there are many members of the West who
unfortunately do act as useful idiots
for Terror groups Rachel Cory was
associated with the international
solidarity movement she was in the Gaza
Strip in Rafa Gaza in 2003 when Israel
was conducting military operations in
the middle of the second in tata uh she
was blocking a site that Israel had
suggested was actually being used to
hide Terror tunnels which as we now know
is a frequent tactic being used in the
Gaza Strip and she uh she planted
herself in the blind spot of a bulldozer
her death was a tragic accident it's
tragic that doesn't mean that she wasn't
acting as a useful idiot on behalf of
far more nefarious forces but she is a
young woman who got bulldozed to death
and this was what 13 years ago and
you're a different character now I just
wonder whether looking back on it you
would have phrased that
differently I mean
perhaps I might phrase it differently
now do I do I feel that she was a fool
and that she was acting on behalf of
Nefarious interests
absolutely let's take a short break Ben
I want to come back and talk to you
about your fascinating trip to aitz with
Elon Musk and about musk himself what
you think of him is he a Force for good
or not we'll come back after the
break we're here thanks for joining yes
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online and on your smart
speaking criminals to using XL Bully
dogs as weapons to threaten others no
matter how well trained most dog owners
will tell you a dog can turn you know
what I love about sport today we do it
all sunak sella
scun a woman can become a man and a man
can become a woman and if you think that
you're certifiably
insane slick Wishy seemed intelligent
forensic even a bit of a Statesman the
type of man man you trust to look after
your house while you went on
holiday this concept that actually kids
wouldn't carry knives if they could go
and play Tiddly Winks at the you know
the corner of the street or whatever I
think it's a
nonsense happy Thurs night we slick it
kurin timorous beasty open up panics in
NY K accused the government of failing a
generation after a record number of
young people were killed last year using
a knife or sharp object we need to make
sure that when we say we're going to ban
them we actually do ban them there are
so many politicians now who just said my
dad was a
boss you're David Cameron no he
wasn't was like brought to you by St KH
the mayor of London very rarely meet
anybody that says you know the thing
about London is it's got a great mayor s
deep Cal brilliant
guy in the cities there are areas where
there are no vegetables it's
particularly difficult for those people
to do what Mark is saying if he comes up
with this argument again I'll sit on
him stop creating all of these funny
little factions with their funny little
names the new conservatives the ERG the
common sense research group the red wool
red trouser popcorn I mean popcorn what
what is that if you're talking about
multiculturalism it's workingclass white
boys who get put in the Army the poorest
people in society are the ones who are
going to be put on the front line
something is going horribly wrong we can
do a lot better Donald Trump didn't just
win he obliterated this is a guy facing
nearly a 100 criminal charges and yet
all that's done is actually Mak him more
popular Trump is canny enough to know
that all publicity is good publicity I
don't want a president who's been
impeached if he's able to bamboozle you
that's the way it comes I did my 6
months I came back nobody would touch me
I put my head down and persisted at
carry down when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are they terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
[Music]
welcome back to P sensor with Ben
Shapiro who last week visited outfits
with Elon Musk Ben uh for you that must
have been a profoundly moving
trip uh it was it was definitely a
difficult trip for sure I'd never been
to aitz before just even on my own and
so that end of itself was deeply
disturbing being being in krackow which
was a city with some 70,000 Jews which
basically has no Jewish presence anymore
because of the Holocaust is obviously a
shocking experience and obviously going
at a time when Jews around the world are
under disproportionate attack makes it
even more shocking and our reminder that
that terrible ideology can have truly
catastrophic consequences as a Jewish
man have you grown up always living with
slight fear with your knowledge of
history that something like that could
happen again again and when you saw what
happened on October the 7th was that the
jolt that you'd always
feared you know I think that as a Jew
obviously you spent an awful lot of time
learning about Jewish history and for
those who know Jewish history the
Holocaust was really the culmination of
a wide series of of mass murders of Jews
over the course of thousands of years uh
so the idea that that Jews are under
threat in a a enormous number of
countries over the course of history is
obviously true and and something that
you understand from the time that you're
very young you know I'm uniquely blessed
as an American citizen America has been
the friendliest country to Jews in world
history Baran it's an unbelievable free
incredible country and learning about
the history of the Holocaust is a
reminder that again when bad ideologies
take over even in places where Jews
think that they are safe I mean Jews
predominantly thought that they were
safe in Germany it was one of the most
sophisticated countries in in all of
Europe Jews fought disproportionately
actually on the side of the Germans
during World War I the when you see that
and when you realiz I that the sort of
conspiracism about Jews that led to the
Holocaust is still very much alive and
well in a lot of different quarters that
is is shocking and October 7th the
reaction by many people in the world to
October 7th which was not to come down
on the head of Hamas but to instead
suggest solidarity with Hamas in many
cases to suggest in in many places on
Earth that actually the Jews were in
disproportionate control of event in
sort of the same conspiratorial language
that we've seen historically the the way
that crosses path with more mainstream
IDE ologies all of that is is certainly
deeply disturbing is there more
anti-Semitism that's come to uh to
public awareness in the last four months
or so than you anticipated or
realized yes for sure I mean if you had
told me that there would be hundreds of
thousands of people marching in
solidarity with Hamas in various
capitals or that college campuses would
become hot beds of anti-Semitism I would
have found that shocking even as cynical
as I am about politics so yes I mean the
rise of anti-Semitism globally in the
wake of October 7th is sort of a
shocking thing especially because again
typically the response of the world in
the wake of large
scale genocidal massacres and when I say
genocidal I don't mean that natural
genocide was perpetrated Kamas doesn't
have the power to perpetrate Natural
genocide they would if they could um but
in in the wake of such massacres
typically um people tend to Rally to the
side of the people who have been Massac
uh in in this particular case again
there was an enormous backlash against
Israel that began literally literally
the the day after I mean there there
were protesters taking to the streets
against Israel before Israel even
launched any retaliatory strikes in the
Gaza Strip and and that I found
absolutely disturbing also again I think
that there is a certain conspiratorial
mindset that has become quite common in
the west I see it more on the left and
on the right but there are certaine
certainly elements of it on the right uh
that that basically suggest that all of
the structures of modern Western life
are rigged that the game is rigged it's
rigged based on based on hierarchical
privilege that the people at the top of
that hierarchy privileged status are
disproportionately white males and that
Jews are a subset of white males and
that you can actually tell who's the
exploiter who's the victimizer by amount
of success in Western society that is a
deeply pernicious idea that tends to
cross paths pretty easily with
anti-Semitism you went with Elon Musk as
I mentioned and he's had pretty rough
ride uh in the last couple of months
after he uh tweeted uh you have said the
actual truth responding to a post that
falsely claim that Jewish people push
hatred for white people he since uh
apologized for that and he went on this
trip with you some people think he is
anti-Semitic I don't think he is but
what was your experience to traveling
with him to
aitz Elon Musk is definitely not an
anti-semite and and for people who are
sort of jumping on various Twitter
comments to suggest that he is I would
suggest that you look at the full Corpus
of everything that he's had to say on
anti-Semitism on Israel uh on what's
going on in the world post October 7th
it's very hard to come to that
conclusion and one of the things that
that I've said about Elon is that Elon
is uh he can be trumpy in the way that
he uses Twitter that he sort of puts out
whatever he's thinking in the moment
unedited uh that's one of the benefits
it's one of the drawbacks uh very often
he will then come back and sort of fill
out exactly what it is that he meant to
say which is what happened in the case
of of that particular tweet um that also
means that he's considering things in
real time which is one of you've
interviewed him I believe and interview
interviewing him is really interesting
that way you'll actually ask him a
question and unlike most people who are
asked interview questions he actually
sits and considers the actual question
he'll take it in you'll see him actually
shift his opinion in real time as he
processes the question it makes him a
fascinating person well it's funny I
wasn't going to say this but you've
you've triggered me by saying you've
interviewed him I haven't interviewed
him I spent a year courting him to do an
interview he finally agreed to do an
interview actually at the start of this
year I was two days away from getting on
a plane from Los Angeles to Austin in
Texas to do it with him and at the last
minute
he suddenly sent me because he was doing
all the organization himself on direct
message on X he suddenly sent me a clip
that someone have posted that day from
an interview I did with zubie at the
start of December in which I criticized
Elon for bringing Alex Jones back to x
uh something he'd always said he
wouldn't do and he said that he'd lost
all respect for me because I had said
that and the interview was summarily
cancelled uh so I never got the chance
to interview him which is a great regret
because I think he's probably the most
fascinating guy in the world right now
it also showed a and you mentioned his
trumpian tweeting a slightly thin skin I
was pretty surprised that someone who is
such a defender of free speech was so
thin skinned about a criticism which
actually a lot of people felt uh he was
right the first time about Jones that
Jones crossed a line that probably did
warrant not being allowed back on the
platform um so so I'm afraid I haven't
interviewed him and that's why so I've
given you a little scoop there
um but on that on that point that he was
upset about do you think Alex Jones
should have been allowed
back so my general belief is that Alex
Jones should not have been banned from
Twitter in the first place because he
didn't actually violate on Twitter their
terms of service and my my belief is
that you should actually have a
consistently applied set of terms of
service that really is less cotty under
the tree deciding who should be banned
and who should not because that gets
into some really dicey areas and you
know living in in fear on Twitter that
you're going to cross an unspecified
line at a certain point and find
yourself on the outs I don't think is
particularly good I've actually never
called for anyone to be banned on
Twitter including many people who
despise me hate my guts and probably
would like to see me dead so I I
actually don't even block people on
Twitter just on principle I refuse to
block people on Twitter it's also why
for example I don't delete old tweets
tweets that I disagree with that I wrote
in 2008 2009 201 I leave those up for
the public record so I tend to be in
favor of radical transparency on X even
if someone has had a billion dooll
defamation case award against them for
deliberately lying about families of
kids who've been blown to pieces in
their classrooms and hasn't paid a penny
or dime of that oh you are certainly not
Piers you are certainly not going to get
me uh to uh to you act in favor of Alex
Jones and I do not get along I think
this is pretty clear publicly uh I I
think that Alex Jones lies a lot I think
Alex Jones promotes conspiracy theories
I think that Alex Jones is a wild
personality and apparently in his
divorce case he claimed that you know
many of the things that he says are for
show you that's that's what Alex does
you know that's that's his shtick but
when it comes to would I ban him from a
platform if I owned a platform as
opposed to for example owning a
publication or being co-owner of
publication which I am over a daily wire
I mean I don't have to hire Alex Jones
at Daily wire to suggest that if you
have an app that's like a Town Square
that even people I absolutely think are
are exorable should be allowed to be on
there one of the best things I think
that that Elon has brought to a is the
community note system which
be used when when people promote lies on
on X I've actually agree with pretty
much everything Elon Musk has said and
done that's why him canceling the
interview was so painful so perhaps
given You're such big buddies you could
put a good word in for your old mate
across the pond could
you I didn't realize I was gonna be
elan's conduit in this interview appear
I've got no other way in now you're my
last you're my last chance because I
actually do think he's a he's a genius
and I think he's actually a Force for
good I asked the question earlier but if
you look at everything he does I I do
think he comes from a place of wanting
to make the world a better place not a
worse place and I think people like him
should be
encouraged I mean I totally agree with
that I mean there the world requires
audacious thinkers Elon Musk is an
audacious thinker the world requires
people who have high aspirations for
Humanity Elon Musk has high aspirations
for Humanity I think that that the chief
the the chief personality thing about
Elon having sat with him for a while is
that Elon is a person who likes to
problems and if the problem is in front
of him he really wants to expend all of
his energy solving it which is why he
will like literally go and sleep on the
factory floor of new companies that he
is working with or starting he will he
will jet set off to I've never seen I
mean the guy's the wealthiest guy on
Earth he certainly doesn't have to go
and sleep on the floor over a Tesla over
a Tesla while he's redesigning their
product or have to go and sleep at the
offices of X as he did when he first
acquired Twitter you that that is
something that only a really dedicated
person would do and uh and I think that
is beyond argument what what Elon is
trying to do even when I disagree with
him is truly an audacious thing he's a
big thinker it's it's a deeply American
ideal I mean to be you know America
Centric here it's a deeply American
ideal to to shoot for the stars and he's
literally doing that so I think that
that that shouldn't be lost in all the
Hub up around whatever he's saying on X
today yeah no I completely agree and
actually you're the perfect person to
put a good word in because you and I
locked horns in spectacular fashion at
CNN but here you are like nothing
happened we are with a with a living
proof of it um let's take a short break
I want to come back and talk about
American politics Trump uh you were a
never Trumper are you still never
Trumper uh and Biden is it really
feasible that the Democrats are going to
go into battle in November with a guy
who can barely stand on his feet or
think straight we'll discuss after the
[Music]
break we're here thanks for joining us
you we talk to TV on TV on radio online
R your smart speaker as well you know
what I love about talk today we do it
all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing o in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a f or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes R unexpected item in
bagging area I know are we only going to
be trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from at Gram was president of the
Cambridge Union which is the rubbish
version of being president of the Oxford
unit
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruise
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut on
Tik Tok problem solv when I say I am God
I'm not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a
rational talk TV is the only place where
you get the
truth this is is talk
[Music]
TV well I'm back with Ben Shapiro who
just to remind the world is currently
number one rapper in the world which
we'll be come to a little later uh Ben
let's talk Donald Trump who's uh really
making one of the all-time great
comebacks that politics has ever seen
not just in America but anywhere he
seems now nailed down for the Republican
nomination and uh polls I saw today show
him significantly up now in almost every
swing state I think against Joe Biden
who is showing increasing signs of of S
sity and dimension now you in 2016 in
March I think it was said this uh about
Trump if we don't say no to Donald Trump
now we will continue drifting ever
further left diluting conservatism into
the vacillating demagogic absurdity of
trumpism conservatism will become the
crypto racist pseudo strong quasy
tyrannical toxic brew leftists have
always accused of being and we will have
been complicit in that how do you feel
today well I mean I was wrong on that
one so that's good I mean you know I
think that in 2016 my objections to
Trump were character-based and they were
sort of looking at the state of the
world and saying I just object to this
choice I didn't vote for Hillary I'm not
voting for Trump that was my take in
2016 so I just didn't vote for president
at the top of the ticket in in 2016 at
all hoping to sort of Forstall the
binary world that then arrived now one
of the things that I was wrong about
with regard to Trump is obviously he
governed much more to my liking in terms
of actual policy than I thought he would
based on his campaign his campaign in
2016 was sort of all over the place it
was quite paretic it was it was you know
in one place on on an issue and then
five minutes later another place on the
same issue but the actual policy that
emerged from his administration
particularly in the first three years of
his administration I liked quite a lot
and so obviously I was wrong about all
of that my character critiques of trump
remained those have not changed even
though I endorsed him in 2020 I
suggested that my opinions of his
character had not shifted particularly
much it was just that my belief was that
we were now down to a binary choice that
many of the eventualities ID hoped to
Forstall by basically not involving
myself in the 2016 election whatever had
happened and now happened and so the
situation had changed I feel the same
way with regard to 20124 so obviously
Trump against Biden I'll vote for Trump
you were in the DeSantis camp
um and he kind of fizzled away uh I
suspect it was really almost out of his
hands in the sense that the moment they
began throwing all the indictments of
trump his poll numbers just began to
Rocket in a way that it was almost
impossible for any other candidate to do
anything about it so I don't really
blame the santis or his campaign I think
it was just an Unstoppable tsunami of
support that flooded in for Trump right
when he most needed it and it came
because the you know the Democrats
decided to play uh throwing the kitchen
Sinker stopping him and by doing that
all they did was embolden him and make
him
stronger I I think there were two main
factors that led to the Revival of trump
in this campaign so as you recall he
actually declared his reelect in
December of 2022 which was incredibly
early and a lot of people were were
skeptical of that including me I thought
that's a very early reelect campaign in
an attempt to basically clear the pool
of all other candidate and DeSantis or
anyone else who's hoping to run against
him if they had really had a shot that
shot was only present if they had gotten
in maybe December January of 2023 the
reason being that there was a widespread
perception in the Republican party that
because of underperformance in 2022 due
to Trump picking bad candidates in the
Senate that made the third straight
election where Trump had lost he had
done poorly in 2020 he had done poorly
in 2021 he' done P poorly in 2022 and so
there was a bit of a taste for something
new but then two things happened one you
mention which is the the indictments
drop and so the Republican party's heart
immediately just reverts to to Trump and
you can see it in the polls dtis is
running even with Trump up till the
indictments the indictments happen Trump
skyrockets D santis Drops in
proportionate amount and and then
there's a second factor and that is Joe
Biden's a terrible president and so as
his poll numbers started to really drop
significantly the big argument that any
other Republican had against Trump which
is he's not electable Biden's going to
beat him that went away because when
every poll is showing Donald Trump
competitive with or ahead of Joe Biden
that argument just doesn't exist anymore
so Dan sans's Chief argument which is
you'll get trumpism without Trump
everyone was like well what if I get
trumpism and also Trump right I get to I
get to have sort of the Trump revenge
tour on the people who are victimizing
him and also he can actually win so
basically the entire case where anyone
else disappeared this election will see
8 million new voters in the US
electorate and 41 million gen Z voters
uh it's apparently according to one poll
18% of Voters say they're more likely or
significantly more likely to vote for a
candidate endorsed by Taylor Swift the
phenomenon of our age and a lot of
conservatives have got very upset about
this and think that she's going to
deliberately
sabotage the the whole thing by saying
vote Biden uh do you think this is a bit
ridiculous this whole debate or is there
a point to
it it's not a little bit ridiculous it's
a lot ridiculous Taylor Swift endorsed
Biden in 2020 so like who cares also
that same poll by the way shows that 17%
of Americans said they would be less
likely to vote for for Joe Biden if
Taylor Swift endorsed Joe Biden so
basically it's a wash you this whole
thing it really is just a sign of our
absurd times that people are focusing
instead of focusing it on like you know
the actual issues like who's going to
run the country and how's that foreign
policy going to be effectuated and is
the economy going to heal everybody's
focused in on is there a CIA conspiracy
around Taylor Swift or is Taylor Swift
really a magical political King maker by
the way everyone is talking about Taylor
Swift mobilizing votes Taylor Swift has
something like 200 Mill million plus I
think it's more it's like 260 million
Instagram followers she put out an
Instagram telling people to register to
vote she got 35,000 people to vote and
people Tre oh that's an enormous 35,000
people 160 million people voted in the
last election cycle like Taylor Swift is
not going to be the Mak or break for Joe
Biden she has had a big effect on NFL
ratings
though that is true when women women are
watching the NFL for the first time and
I will say that my conspiracy theory was
that if Lamar Jackson in the Baltimore
had been on the brink of actually
beating the Kansas City Chiefs in the
AFC Championship Lamar Jackson might
have actually been drone stried by Roger
Goodell from the NFL higher offices
because the NFL desperately needs the
Kansas City Chiefs in the Super Bowl I'm
putting aside her politics um I would
imagine that Taylor Swift is pretty much
your idea of of a good role model isn't
she for young young girls in
particular I mean my my only critique of
Taylor Swift is that she's 34 and all of
her songs sound like a 17-year-old going
through her first breakup that that's my
only critique is that she's two years
younger than my wife my wife is a doctor
and we have four kids and Taylor Swift
is 34 and single and still acting like
she's in the dating pool and that that's
my only critique of Taylor Swift I my
great hope for Taylor Swift is that
Travis Kelce proposes to her she gets
married to Travis Kelce they have lots
of babies and a bunch of young feminist
women decide that actually marriage is
not the worst idea and they get married
and have a bunch of babies and we can
have the Taylor Swift Baby
Boom are you a are you a secret Swifty
Ben
uh I'm definitely not a secret Swifty uh
I I mean listen I'm a rap Legend So
frankly that's not even my bag yo but
we're going to come back after the break
we're going to talk about your
astonishing rise to number one in the
rap music charts how has this happened
why has this happened and what does it
say about America that's after the
[Music]
break we're here thanks for joining us
yes you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online and on your smart
speaking criminals to using XL Bully
dogs as weapons to threaten others no
matter how well trained most dog owners
will tell you a dog can turn you know
what I love about to today we do it all
sunak sella
scun a woman can become a man and a man
can become a woman and if you think that
you're certifiably
insane slick Wishy seemed intelligent
forensic even a bit of a Statesman the
type of man you trust to look after your
house while you went on
holiday this concept that actually kids
wouldn't carry knives if they could go
and play Tiddly Winks at the you know
the corner of the street or whatever I
think it's a
nonsense happy THS night we slick it
Kuran timorous beasty open up panics in
nisty K stas accused the government of
failing a generation after a record
number of young people were killed last
year using a knife or sharp object we
need to to make sure that when we say
we're going to ban them we actually do
ban them there are so many politicians
now who just said my dad was a
boss you're David Cameron no he
wasn't was like brought to you by St KH
the mayor of London very rarely meet
anybody that says you know the thing
about London is it's got a great mayor
it's a deep Cal brilliant
guy in the cities there are areas where
there are no vegetables it's
particularly difficult for those people
to do what Mark is saying if if he comes
up with this argument again I'll sit on
him stop creating all of these funny
little factions with their funny little
names the new conservatives the ERG the
common sense research group the red wool
red trouser popcorn I mean popcorn what
what is that if you're talking about
multiculturalism it's workingclass white
boys who get put in the Army the poorest
people in society are the ones who are
going to be put on the front line
something is going horribly wrong we can
do a lot better Donald Trump didn't just
win he obliterated this is a guy facing
nearly a 100 criminal charges and yet
all that's done is actually Mak him more
popular Trump is canny enough to know
that all publicity is good publicity I
don't want a president who's been
impeached if he's able to bamboozle you
that's the way it comes did my 6 months
I came back nobody would touch me I put
my head down and persisted at carry down
when I say I am God I'm not joking did
you feel Elvis was controlling I I've
been answering your question you answer
mine it's actually not my job to answer
your questions I've asked you two
questions should a mass stay in power
and are they a teror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
coming up tonight on the independent
republic of mik gr we're going to be
speaking to Harmony London she's the
woman they tried to stop from singing
because the police officer told her you
can't sing those songs unless you're
inside a church or in church grounds she
is a brilliant singer and we're going to
hear from her this night on the
independent republic of Mike Graham
don't miss it after
9:00 welcome back to senson Ben Shapiro
is still with me now Ben four years ago
you were pretty scathing in your
criticism of rap and
hip-hop from the outside when I listen
to hip-hop I I don't hear a lot of
family oriented messages in fact I hear
a lot of messages that are degrading to
women I hear messages that that push
violence uh that are disparaging to the
police uh I hear messages very often
that seem to treat H relationships
between men and women as something
disposable or or glorify
mistreatment yet here you are the same
Ben Shapiro the rap hater here's a clip
from your number one
hit let's at the STS got the my money
like Liz my pockets are fatom I'm epic
don't be a WAP dog it's yomie no cap
look at the graphs look at my charts
you're blowing money on strippers and
cars you go into prison I'm on
televisions no one knows who you are
keeping on me on the internet my com
section all and I make RS off compound
interest y live with your parents Nik
notes I just did this for fun all my
people download this let's get aill
number
one so first question how did we get
from that first clip to the second
one you know life is a journey piers and
I've decided to to take that Journey one
step at a time just never know what life
is going to throw your way if my parents
had known when they spent you thousands
of dollars on 15 years of classical
violin lessons with some of the best
teachers in the world that my musical
career would culminate in me at the top
of the world rap charts I think they I
can only think that they would be
incredibly proud they just just so proud
that they they spent all of that time
that I wouldn't at least clap on one and
three so that's that's very very
exciting stuff and and yes I mean we're
taking over the industry from the inside
Tom McDonald is the real talent behind
all of that obviously Tom Tom can
actually rap Tom's actually good at this
the entire joke of me being part of the
rap is I think the funniest thing in the
world and and I'm really enjoying a lot
of the reaction videos which people
hysterically laughing at the fact that I
even attempt to thing so uh you know
good good for good for Tom and uh and
good for everybody who's sort of in on
the prank because I think there's actual
very good shot that we end up at the
billbo number one no question and and I
think you should because it's based
around facts which is from your great
quote uh facts don't care about your
feelings I think it's your pinned tweet
it's still there had gazillions of
people who like it and I've always like
that because it kind of sums up to me
the facade of wokery which is that it's
all feeling driven and very rarely fact
driven and in fact all the lyrics of
this which you know you send up rap
music very uh very cleverly but also in
Tom's uh lyrics go work go broke no hope
it's pathetic pro-choice prouns Pro love
your progresses and so on and so on
where are the American flags that
remember when people would hang those
they've been taken down replaced with
BLM Flags or a rainbow and so on it will
hit a nerve with people who feel like
their their country is no longer
somewhere that they feel comfort able in
or recognize because the woke Brigade
have made everyone or tried to make
everyone feel so ashamed of what it
means to be an American or what it means
to be
British I think that's exactly right
it's why Tom has resonated so much as an
independent artist now the fact is that
there are a lot of systemic kind of
barriers to to entry for for song like
some of the ones that Tom has made
before which are very rightwing uh which
are very conservative in orientation and
I think think that a lot of the
resonance that you're seeing to this is
a rejection of many of the values that
I'm actually talking about in that clip
uh from one of my shows where I'm
talking about the sort of stuff that
that rap is is promoting and we're
trying to promote the exact opposite one
of the lyrics in the song that that Tom
actually wraps is that we are not going
to turn your sons into thugs or your
daughters into ho meaning like we're
actually trying to promote social
responsibility and and good citizenship
in a wrap which is again I think part of
the humor but hopefully some people
listen to it and they think well maybe
you know there's an alternative point of
view that's worth listening to here you
know always got my goat about it it's
the it's the ridiculous double standard
and I'll give an example when John
Legend decided to take upon himself to
rewrite the lyrics to Baby It's Cold
Outside one of the most innocent songs
and videos ever created in music history
and yet he didn't he decided to cleanse
it up to make it me too friendly uh
because apparently it was involving
sexual assault although everybody knows
it wasn't U but he didn't say a word
about any of his rap friends and their
truly disgusting violent misogynist
lyrics I didn't cross his mind to
rewrite one of those because that
wouldn't have given him Street
Credibility that would have damaged him
whereas playing the we've got to clean
up this shocking Baby It's Cold Outside
that was a virtue signaling
winner oh absolutely the attempt to wipe
away history to wipe away old culture
because old culture is bad and we have
better values now that stops right at
the front door when it comes to rap when
it comes to hip hop and rap I mean any
song that you pick up is going to be the
most retro grade values that you ever
heard if you're a progressive and you
listen to rap I'm not sure exactly how
you squar that frankly because a lot of
the stuff that's promoted in rap is
mistreatment of women treating of women
as Commodities drugs and the the the
attempts to promote violence I mean all
these messages are really bad and kids
do in fact embibe them so if we can send
that up at the same time that we're
doing something successful like this and
also do something as as hilarious as you
know put a a you know Jew life crew over
here at the top of the rap charts uh
then uh that that that's that's a win
for everybody there was a touch of the
nm's about you I got to say M&M's about
you the the hoodie the the whole look
the movements
everything oh yeah benim M benim we've
got it that's the one um I I was
watching you talking to Jordan Peterson
uh I think it was a couple of days ago
and he was saying you know we're talking
about society and where it's all gone
and he was like you know what once you
reach a point where people can't say
what a woman is society's kind of gone
so nuts it's very hard to work out what
we're living in and I'm sure that in 20
years time we'll look back and think
what the hell was going on and how do we
ever let this happen you know we've got
to the stage now where Leah Thomas this
Infamous transgender swimmer in America
uh who's decimating women's uh sport in
the swimming pool now wants to compete
in the Olympics and literally steal a
place in the American Olympic team if
she's successful Miss
from a biological female uh what do you
think about
this I mean again it's absurd but I
think it goes to something we were
talking about earlier and we were
talking about sort of the rise of
conspiracism the reason that so many
conspiracy theories seem less
conspiratorial than they used to is
because there are in fact a Cadre of
Elites particularly in sort of Legacy
Media who promote ideas that are so
counter to just basic common sense and
then demand that you actually abide by
those ideas that you repeat the nostrums
and the aphorisms over and over in in
almost maest struggle session ways that
of course A lot of people are feeling
like there's a sort of conspiracy of
people who don't share your values and
are tempting to cram those down on you
the problem is of course when that
metastasizes into broader critiques of
this racial group or that racial group
that starts to get really really
dangerous but yes I mean the simple fact
that that the question of man versus
woman do they exist is Up For Debate it
says that there is something
fundamentally sick about the society now
it's my view that the only way that you
can can actually rebuild societies you
can't do it top down you actually have
to do it bottom up which is why when
people ask me what can I do to help
because politics seems it's so hard I
mean there's so much stuff going on and
the world's on fire and everything the
best thing you can do be a responsible
husband if you're a man be a responsible
parent be a responsible citizen be a
member of your religious community build
the local institutions that actually
facilitate trust and then you can build
those up such that broader institutions
can be built on top of that but it's
going to require a full rebuilding
effort yeah it is um one of the things I
I really like about you Ben apart from
the fact you're staggeringly successful
uh businessman through the portal of
your opinions which I'm fully signed up
to um is it you you're very comfortable
and willing in fact eager to get into
the debating Fray with people who
completely disagree with it you're quite
happy to engage with the enemy in that
sense but we live in an era where so
many people are now too terrified to do
that they only want to exist in their
tribe driven by social media what do we
do about that
I mean frankly I think that all you can
do is try to use your platform to talk
with people of various sides who who
disagree with you now again I think that
there is such a thing as an Overton
window right I'm not interested in
sitting down with somebody who's
espousing the murder of all Jews for
example I I agree with you there is such
a thing as the Overton window with that
said you know I think that good faith
conversations happening across the aisle
is deeply important not only because it
clarifies positions but also it does
rebuild that social trust that is
clearly falling apart because one of the
biggest problems we have is what what
I've termed sort of the happy birthday
problem which is you know you're a
public figure appears how many people do
you know who will text you happy
birthday but will not tweet it for fear
that they might receive blowback simply
for recognizing that you were born of
woman that sort of problem is the is is
the sort of thing that I think
fundamentally carves away at a society
because we can at least acknowledge that
we're part of the same civilization that
we share probably 80% of our values even
if we disagree strenuously on the other
20% that's not a civilization that can
be that can be preserved no I agree uh
Ben we've run out of time I love talking
to you please come back whenever you can
fit Us in uh the Ben show is fantastic
the daily wire is fantastic uh I love
the uncensored opinions you bring and I
love you coming on uncensored so thank
you very much indeed for joining
me where
appears that's it for me whatever you're
up to like me and Ben keep it un sensed
good
[Music]
night
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
talk today we do it all sunak sella
guns I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this Hammer
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rock gets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sunak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police appr Pro Palestine that is just
not right you swear an o in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for sadique Khan we're not stopping
until you
stop the the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £40
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC Mouse
man MC mous man he should be easy enough
to catch this guy shouldn't he I mean
he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden this decided this was important
after watching a Tom Cruz film do you